farmer linga kassan is heading to a
forest on the island of borneo
in recent years he's planted around a
thousand trees on his seven hectares of
land where there was once just bare
earth
he sees the work as an investment in his
future
but i might wait until the trunk is more
than 30 centimeters wide then i'll get
the maximum price for it
[Music]
also keeps oil palms and rubber trees
but they don't yield enough profit
so in 2016 he was among the first to
sign up for a reforestation project
it aims to create sustainable forests
and provide an income for local people
it includes growing crops to avoid
creating a monoculture
the farmers are allowed to chop down
some of the larger trees to sell
more than a thousand farmers are now
involved in the project dubbed 100
million trees
indonesia has lost nearly a fifth of its
forests in just the last 20 years
some were cleared for gold mining like
here
the damage to the environment that comes
from gold mining is huge
as the project manager explains
it used to be a force
but after a year
it become like this
they basically flipped uh the sand
and then bring the top soil
inside the
in the inside part so it's almost
impossible to enforce this area
and then
it's very high risk job
because in the process they're using
dangerous chemicals such as mercury
and of course it's very bad for the
environment as well as the people
but unfortunately
this is one of the few source of incomes
for the local people here
so it's vital to create alternative
sources of income
mona lisa
is reaching out to the gold miners
hoping to bring them into the
reforestation project
they are actually very open to new ideas
as long as it is not illegal you know
they are not risking their lives this is
what we try to bring through the rangers
through 100 million trees
[Music]
this former forest was burned down to
make way for a palm oil plantation
now a new forest is being planted here
many local villages are pitching in
that allows them to earn some extra
money
it's being financed by private investors
and the german government's
international climate initiative
the farmers get the seedlings directly
from fair ventures once they receive
training on how and where to plant them
today kaharap is visiting farmer pasihan
he's only been involved in the project
for a year but he's already planted
several hundred sengon trees
the sengon is very fast growing
around
five to six meters in 11 months this is
why we love this kind of trees so much
because you know the more they grow the
more nitrogen they put in the soil the
more fertilizes the soil and that it
allows the farmers to actually plant any
other things in his field
and yeah this is how fast
it's growing and then imagine
a million million of trees in central
kalimantan
was planted by the farmers here
to absorb the carbon
for the farmer it's not only about
providing a stable income for himself
and later his children
like in many parts of borneo floods are
a growing problem here
these days our village floods three to
four times a year
it used to only flood once a year
but it doesn't seem to matter anymore
what the season is we still get flooded
i think it's down to the impact of
mining
the forest has been cleared so the
ground doesn't absorb the water anymore
and when it rains heavily
everywhere just floods
planting more trees could help prevent
such damaging floods in the future
more than a million new trees have been
planted throughout the region so far
some of them will now be felled and sold
as timber while others are planted in
their place
the idea is to attract more business to
borneo to help the farmers
the timber industry in indonesia now
it's still very centralized in java
island right and then we try to convince
the industry to also
invest in kalimantan or what we're
trying to do is we try to connect the
farmers directly with the industry to
cut down the
middleman which is you know we try to
to make it more
to make the most profit for the farmers
through this system
farmer linga kasan who's been involved
from the start is optimistic
he's hoping that the 100 million trees
initiative will improve his life in the
long term while also benefiting the
environment
you